hey man it's me kevin smith we are going
to take a look at the
clerks 37 scene you know uh the scene
that i
may in fact have put me on the map the
scene that
like my whole career may be predicated
on that 37 dick scene
um we played at sundance of course back
in 1994
and i distinctly remember the movie
really taken off at that scene you know
in the first like 12 13 minutes of the
movie
i was biting my nails going like it's
not a lot of laughs i mean [ __ ]
maybe i should cut all this [ __ ] but
people just getting cozy and comfy and
familiar with the characters by the time
you got to the 37 dick scene
that's when the roller coaster ride
began and stuff so
this scene may be responsible for my
entire
uh career it's brian o'halloran and
marilyn gigliotti playing dante
and veronica who both returned in clerks
three which we start shooting this year
um and and uh both of them
give a wonderful performances opposite
the
the uh producer of the film uh
as played by uh willem black character
his name was as played by
scott mosher um scott moser originally
was gonna play him as a real slickster
he was written as a real like hey man
hey ron ron how you been been like that
kind of guy
but instead moser went for a stoner
which i'm like don't we have enough of
those in that movie already
uh but jay's stoner was completely
different moses was like that's
cool man like keeping it real
chi-chi-chong and [ __ ] like that
so uh this scene maybe if you're ever
like i [ __ ] hate kevin smith why does
he have a career
it's this scene right here man enjoy the
37
scene from clerks willem
oh hey ronnie how you been man
what do you work here now no i was
visiting my man dante this is willem
black
this is dante hicks my boyfriend how are
you doing just decided
no and a pack of cigarettes
so where you been man you still going to
seton hall
no i i transferred into monmouth this
year i was tired of missing him
that's beautiful man
so you still talked to silva i just
talked to her on monday
we still hang out on weekends oh that's
great
well you two lovebirds take it easy okay
bye take it easy
that was snowball why do you call him
that
silly made it up it's a [ __ ] thing
what do you mean
after he gets a [ __ ] he likes to have
it spit back into his mouth while
kissing it's called snowballing he
requests this
he gets off on it still didn't get me
talked into anything
why do you say that well like you said
she snowballed
sylvan no i i snowballed him yeah right
i'm serious you sucked that guy's dick
yeah how do you think i knew that he
wait but you said you only had sex with
three different guys you never mentioned
him
because i never had sex with him you
sucked his dick we went out a few times
we never had sex but we fooled around
oh my god why did you tell me i needed
sex with three different guys
because i did only have sex with three
different guys that doesn't mean i
didn't just go with people oh my god i
feel so nauseous
i'm sorry dante i thought you understood
i did understand
i understood that you had sex with three
different guys and that's all you said
please calm down
how many daunting how many dicks have
you sucked
shut up a second and i'll tell you jesus
i didn't freak out like this when you
told me how many girls you [ __ ]
this is different this is important how
[Music]
many
well
something like 36 what
something like 36. oh your voice what is
that anyway something like 36 does that
include me
um 37 i'm 37 going to class
oh my god 37 my girlfriend stuck 37
dicks in a row hey kids did you like
that all these movies are available on
itunes or netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with you all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith